a dramatic win for England and it goes
bronze a ride got the touchdown Kelly's
in there the documents
the winning goal by Chloe Kelly during
extra time crowned England Euro 2022
champions for the first time the final
score two to one against Germany
[Applause]
history made before 87 000 fans in a
sold out Wembley Stadium the highest
attendance of any European Championship
final men's or women's
yeah
outside the stadium celebrations echoed
across England including London's
Trafalgar Square it just shows what a
milestone we've hit and I just think
keep going keep winning more trophies
the atmosphere in there was so nice it
was warm it was happy
fans say the sport suspense and victory
has United the nation and inspired
future generations and players are
soaking it all in right now just enjoy
the moment all the fans are home enjoy
the moment because you don't know when
you get days like this again so yeah
enjoy every minute of it after a
multiple Championship wins German fans
were shocked at their loss
but face no other option but to accept
defeat
it was incredible
it was truly amazing because like it
only happens four years in Germany have
one like eight times so it was very
exciting and it was a great opportunity
for me to be there
of the European Champions the queen has
congratulated the inspirational
lionesses on their historic win adding
their success goes far beyond the trophy
now the new Euro Champs are enjoying
that success for their team country and
their sport
[Applause]
Al Jazeera
so let's